[Musique]
pour voir christophe alors je vais te
spécialiste en équitation éthologique
c'est quoi les qui coaching alors
l'équipe coaching c'est là la mise aux
situations d'un d'un être humain avec un
cheval les chevaux sont dotés d'une
hypersensibilité et sont extrêmement
doués pour déceler nos propres émotions
notre propre intériorité et pour ainsi
dire c'est une forme de rendez vous avec
vous mais je suis invité à faire le tour
des box et choisir le cheval avec lequel
je sens que le thème du secret et
ensuite je vous inviterai à rentrer dans
le box ça ça va être un petit peu
difficile
et si c'est un peu difficile n'hésitez
pas à vous me demandez moi je peux vous
accompagnez d'accord
[Musique]
nous partons ensuite sur une autre série
d'exercices aux manèges ont travaillé
quelque chose de plus intérieure vous
allez vous mettre à bonne distance de
jean et vous avez un beau rapproché
d'elle un travaillant le un des
mouvements du bébé qui est le aller vers
et je suis là juste pour vous lier un
tout petit peu et vous avancez on en
essayant de prendre conscience de ce
qu'est ce que ça vous fait de vous
rapprocher du cheval est d'aller vers
lui
certains présentent mari d'elsa
maintenant on va passer sur un autre
petit atelier et je vais vous demander
simplement de prendre à temps pour vous
et pour elle vous allez essayer de créer
du lien avec ces objets je dois essayer
de capter l'attention de la jument pour
la mettre en mouvement
mais ici aussi ce n'est pas très
concluant
/
[Musique]
en fait j'ai pas du tout envie de la
diriger moi vous avez pas envie de la
mairie je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il
faisait rien tu as là et pourquoi vous
n'avez pas envie de diriger ce n'est pas
l'avis la laisser tranquille
d'accord c'est après avoir exprimé mon
ressenti que la jument s'est mise à me
suivre le lien été créé ça on peut
rebondir là dessus mind si vous l'aviez
en bts qu'elle est qu elle vous
accompagne lorsque vous reculez d'accord
marylène est ce que cette expérience où
vous a plu vous qui n'avez pas
l'habitude des chevaux mais c'est
intéressant mais là j'ai pu j'ai plus
peur avec elle bilan de cette séance
je n'ai plus peur des chevaux et je sais
qu'une direction n'est pas forcément une
contrainte